you know for all of the claims that the  IRS is picking on the very rich a new  report finds that the IRS actually  disproportionately targeted the poorest  taxpayers and that millionaires mostly  went unscathed even Fox News admits that  this is what a report says now there's  an interesting thing to this not only is  it sort of weird because it's different  than the story we've been told it's also  arguably not the best financial use of  the IRS resources which are limited  because even if a poor person underpaid  their taxes by 50 percent the number of  dollars you will recover by auditing  them is far smaller than what you would  get from a very rich person if they  underpaid their taxes by even only 10 or  15 percent